this is the origin 800 the world's first
swappable modular power station which is
meant to reinvent what you think a power
station should be and honestly their
idea was absolutely genius instead of
having a single power station they
thought of a clever modular system with
detachable power Stacks that work
independently so in this video I'm gonna
go through the five main features that
make this thing great but first starting
with the specs the origin 800 can output
800 watts of power which is super
impressive for its size having 13 total
output ports and it accepts charging
from various different methods like a
100 watt USBC fast charging input a 200
watt solar charging input and a UPS
input which I'll explain in this video
now getting into the main feature number
one we have the main power hub which is
loaded with 288w
hours of battery power which is enough
to fully charge a new 15-inch MacBook
Air over four times on the back it has
two regular AC Outlets with up to 800
watts of power so you can plug in
various appliances or anything else
while on the front it has a cool display
that shows you the battery life charging
input and output power and more you also
have four USB ports two of them USB a
with up to 18 watts of output power and
two USBC ports with up to a hundred
Watts which has a ton of power so you
can fast charge even the biggest
MacBooks you then have two 130 watt DC
outputs one being a car output for
devices like inflatable air pumps and
one that can accept things like laptop
chargers or things like electric
four-wheelers which our kids love to use
but that's not the best part about the
origin 800 which brings us into feature
number two unlike basically every other
Power Station out there this one is
totally unique unique because it comes
with these power Stacks that it
recharges through electrical contacts so
they can be used independently as
separate power Banks each with 86.4 Watt
hours of battery which is enough to
fully charge an iPhone 14 pro seven
times each stack comes with a 60 watt
USBC port for fast charging and
recharging away from the power hub and
the power Dock at the top is really cool
because it comes with this handle and
four extra USB a ports that support 18
watt charging and it comes with a 10
watt wireless charging pad on the top
each one also comes with an LED ring
which can also show you your battery
life by double pressing the side button
which is very convenient but the most
impressive part of all is feature number
three which is the ability to lock and
unlock the stacks each stack comes with
an electrically controlled mechanism
that can lock so that they're fully
interconnected so you can use the handle
the top to carry the entire thing around
when you place the power Stacks onto the
main battery they automatically lock
into place so they can start recharging
and then to unlock them just hold the
side button and Bam it unlocks allowing
you to lift either a single power stack
to or all of them at once depending on
how much battery power you need but I
personally prefer splitting them into
solo Stacks which allows for many
different locations where people can
charge up their devices now getting into
feature number four this also comes with
a UPS feature which keeps power
uninterrupted in the case of a power
outage making it perfect for connecting
computers for important work like
editing files or best of all it's super
important for CPAP machines making it
always useful even when you're not in a
camping environment and then finally for
feature number five we have the built-in
AI assistant that's voice controlled
that allows you to do things like
activate the LED lights and control the
ace C and DC ports making it really
convenient without having to walk up and
physically control them now since this
is a pre-production prototype unit there
were a couple of issues with charging
and unlocking and locking the pucks but
they should all be ironed out by the
time this thing launches including
different accessories like a lamp or a
modular Cub cooler as well so overall
the origin 800 is an absolutely great
power station that takes it to the next
level with the swappable battery packs
making it so much more useful than any
other power station on the market so if
you're interested in checking this out
go ahead and use the links down below to
check out their Indiegogo page for the
you Adam origin 800. thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign